here with reaction I call him the great
one the host of the number one show on
weekends here on Fox life liberty Levin
nationally syndicated radio host the
great one thank me God bless us how am I
Sean I'm going to do something now
that's never been done I don't believe
in the history of cable I don't need all
the time you gave me to tell the
American people what should stake here
first of all the idea that they're
bringing in Barack Obama
people forget under Barack Obama two
terms as president the Democrats lost
1030 Democrat seats in the state
legislatures federal Governors so I say
if Barack Obama wasn't coming in the RNC
should pay him to come in he's a
disaster when it comes to elections
Joe Biden is the Herbert Hoover of our
time except that Herbert Hoover had
compassion and he had a heart
uh Joe Biden does not neither do the
Democrats they deny there's inflation
they denies there's recession uh they
are obsessively focused on partial birth
abortion that's sick you wake up every
morning thinking about that meanwhile
they don't support law and order they
don't support the cops who protect
women's bodies rape is going through the
roof and so forth uh here's the problem
let me say this to you Democrats
we don't want your socialist crap
we don't want your centralized power
we don't want bureaucrats making our
health care decisions
we don't want you destroying our
economic system
we're not buying off on this climate
change that's destroying our energy
Independence
keep your damn hands off our children
keep your pornography out of our
elementary school libraries you can
stick your critical race Theory where it
doesn't shine we're not interested in
any of it we don't want an open border
where foreigners come across here like
they own the country
and so many of them we don't know the
number we don't know who they are
and we do know some are bringing
Fentanyl and killing the people in this
country 18 to 49 years old in record
numbers
keep that border secure
Joe Biden is completely lacking in
compassion you have all kinds of sex
trading going on down there little kids
being molested down there Joe Biden's
sort of shuffling around going from one
point of the country to the other the
one place he won't go to is the southern
border in fact I don't know of any
Democrat who wants to go to the southern
border because they don't want to see
what they've done to the country this
country was rolling along the economy
was expanding people had jobs gasoline
was affordable we had no inflation the
Border was Secure under Trump all these
things were going well and the Democrat
Party comes in with a wrecking ball his
name's Joe Biden and he's got a a
Congress that marches right behind him I
hear this said that they're moderate
Democrats out there there's no moderate
Democrat out there every damn one of
them voted for socialism every damn one
of them voted for inflation every damn
one of them voted to drive up energy
costs in this country not one of them
except a few On the Border have fought
his open border policies not one not one
of them has taken any serious stance for
Law and Order period we have ma'am in
the streets most of the streets where
the ma'am is occurring controlled by the
Democrats we have lousy education system
in this country because the teachers
unions are too political and they bought
and paid for the Democrat Party and so
our teaching scores are excuse me our
student scores are are in the toilet now
if you want more of this America it's
there for you it's only been less than
two years you want four years of this
you want five million illegal aliens
coming across the border because the
Democrat Party is a disaster
now I've got two minutes left and I'm
giving it back to you if you don't vote
in 19 days you're going to lose your
country it's that simple
Mark let me add one thing and that is
and we really don't talk a lot about it
if the Democrats did win what does that
mean for the country as bad as bad as
things are now all the issues you
touched on all the issues I'm touching
on think about this then we get the
elimination of the legislative
filibuster then we get Court packing
then we get DC statehood then we get
Puerto Rico statehood then we get the
authoritarianism of the democratic party
and they will forever alter the the
greatest system of governance ever
created for man that's how deep that's
how profound this will be on this
country and I don't know if we get to
the point where we could never recover
at that point
no we won't let me tell you what we'll
get a depression because these fools
believe the more you spend the more you
control inflation
if they win they will consider
themselves being empowered and having a
mandate if they win we're going to have
a depression if they win we're going to
have 5 million illegal aliens if they
win your children have no hope in our
Public Schools if they win the police
state that they've put together with the
FBI and the Department of Justice will
not only focus on parents and focus on
pro-life groups and so forth they will
continue their assault on Republicans
Donald Trump and other potential
candidates it's completely out of
control what else if they win Mayhem in
the streets will continue it's just
incredible it's like uh the Democrat
Party has done more listen to this hold
on now the Democrat Party has done more
to damage our country
to damage our country economically in
terms of law enforcement and crime in
terms of the Border then communist China
and Russia could do together on their
best day we're being destroyed from
within right now and that includes the
military that's how bad this is
when you look at the polls and it's
44-44 in Georgia for the Senate and it's
4646 in Pennsylvania for the Senate and
and then you look in Nevada and Adam
laxalt up by one and you look in Arizona
Blake Masters down by one why do you
think it's so close or do you not
believe these polls
I don't care about the polls I don't
know if it's close or not whether it's
politics or military operations
you act like you're behind you act like
the enemies on the offense we can enjoy
the polls afterwards and all the rest
these Point these polls to me are
deleterious you act like you're 10
points behind in every one of these
races and I have a comment for Mitch
McConnell two months ago as the
Republican leader you criticized our
candidates let me tell you something we
have great candidates we have citizen
candidates people with all kinds of
backgrounds just because they don't come
out of Washington in the establishment
you don't condemn them so I think these
candidates are doing a great job in
America
it's up to you
that's it
I'm done you're supposed to you forgot
the I'm done part where's the I'm done
where's that part I was done two minutes
ago
all right that's why we call them the
great one hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else